foreign
[Music]
the new Spider-Man across the
spiderverse has been running in cinemas
for some time now the high expectations
of fans and critics have been met in
every respect so the movie is a worthy
successor to the popular into the
spider-verse in today's original we take
a look at the next movie in the series
namely Spider-Man beyond the
spider-verse which is due for release
next year of course there might be some
spoilers since we'll be talking about
the plot of part 2. we will also include
content from the comics for theories
about part 3 which obviously don't
necessarily have to make it into the
film so for those who haven't seen
across the spider-verse yet call your
friends go to the movies and then come
back to this video
now many are wondering what will happen
next in Spider-Man beyond the
spider-verse since there was no
post-credits scene at the end of across
the spider verse there is no
straightforward clue yet as to whether
we can expect a particular surprising
twist nevertheless there are plenty of
unresolved endings that could be picked
up plus a few Easter eggs that might
already reveal to us what will become
important in part three
let's start by stating the obvious it is
safe to assume that the team around
spider-gwan has an interest in
maintaining the spider-verse but that
also means that they want to thwart
miles plans to save his father we can
probably expect a big conflict between
miles and his former team here however
many fans suspect a surprising twist in
which Miles mother will die in the end
this theory is not too far-fetched after
all something like that also happens in
the comics
the spider-verse led by Spider-Man 2099
might also hold a dark secret already
during the movie there is some tension
between Gwen and Miguel she doesn't seem
to trust the leader very much also in
one scene you can see that his mask has
vampire-like features which could be a
reference to the comics they are the
main villain is the initially mentioned
Moreland who in turn is the leader of
his own vampire family it is therefore
quite possible that Spider-Man 2099
hides more behind his mask and has his
own agenda
but there is also the villain's spot who
keeps seeing miles as an enemy and wants
to kill his father the fact that spot is
getting more and more powerful due to
his ever increasing number of spots on
his body has already been seen in the
movie even at the beginning of the
second film when spot is not anywhere
near as powerful as he is at the end he
was an extremely tough villain to defeat
it seems likely that he can't be beaten
without an alliance of all the available
spider-verse Heroes however it is
improbable that spot will be the only
bad guy that Miles spider-gwen and the
likes will have to deal with indeed a
number of fans believe that the
so-called Sinister Six will make their
debut in the spider-verse in part 3. on
Earth 42 for example Jay Jonah Jameson
mentions The Sinister Six cartel also
there are many company names that have
striking similarities to the members of
the antagonist Squad including for
example the vulture Corp a sandman style
Rolex the electrophone and many more in
addition to the three Easter eggs there
are references to Dr Octopus Mysterio
and Craven the hunter while none of
these things provide clear evidence we
can well imagine that this Theory will
later become reality
another storyline that will gain
significance is the yet to be unveiled
revelation of Miles identity to his
family speaking of identity in the
second film miles are shown to have a
very different career on the
crime-ridden earth 42 with none of the
superhero Fame in fact on this planet
miles is none other than Prowler and
it's not unlikely that we will learn
more about the latter's history another
reason is that mahershala Ali as uncle
Aaron and Donald Glover as Prowler are
two top-class actors who have been
signed up for the dubbing and it would
seem appropriate to show more of them
than their comparatively short
appearance in Spider-Man across the
spider-verse as you can see many
questions remain unanswered and for some
the ending of across the spider-verse
may be unsatisfactory due to the
Cliffhanger the weight for the story's
closure in part three shouldn't take too
long as the planned release is barely
nine months away
the team for beyond the spider verse
remains mostly the same joaquim dos
Santos Kemp powers and Justin K Thompson
return as the directing Trio Phil Lord
and Chris Miller will also keep on
working as screenwriters and will finish
telling the story together with Dave
Callahan in addition Daniel Pemberton
once again provides the movie score the
unchanged staff is hardly surprising
after all across the spider-verse and
Beyond the spider-verse are considered
one coherent movie in terms of story
content the situation is similar when it
comes to the cast here too all the key
characters are expected to make another
appearance in an interview with collider
however Lord and Miller hinted that
despite the numerous returnees there is
still plenty of room for surprises one
possibility for example could be Cindy
Moon AKA silk who also get her own
series later on in addition a
Spider-Woman animated movie is being
considered a Miles Morales live action
movie is in the works and Spider-Man 4
with Tom Holland is likewise in
development here they could take the
opportunity to set things up with
appearances in beyond the spiderverse
will the release of beyond the
spiderverse be postponed the fact that
Parts 2 and 3 are closely related can
also be seen in the proximity of the
release dates the development of the
second film began even prior to the
release of into the spider-verse in 2018
while part 3 is now scheduled to be
released just a few months after its
predecessor however as Spider Gwen star
Haley Steinfeld recently told us she
currently hasn't voiced a single
sentence for part three while that had
been the case for part 2 over a period
of 4 years we hope that this is not a
bad sign for the planned theatrical
release of Spider-Man beyond the
spider-verse on March 29 2024 and hope
for an early culminating conclusion of
the film series
and that's it for our new original we
hope you enjoyed our theories regarding
Spider-Man across the spider-verse what
are your ideas about the upcoming third
and presumably last movie of the planned
Trilogy around Miles Morales and the
others which of the new Spider-Man
projects are you most looking forward to
and how did you actually like the
current installment questions upon
questions write us your responses in the
comments
[Music]
foreign